all right the Sterling Club the sponsors
of the segment open their doors to
people looking to plan a very special
event especially a luxurious one
hi I am Alexandra bateria I am the
Director of Events sales and
celebrations at the Sterling Club the
Sterling Club is a private luxurious
social club and event venue located
minutes away from the strip and walking
distance from the Las Vegas Convention
Center we host all types of events at
the club you can host everything for
your wedding celebration from your
bridal party to your rehearsal dinner
and your post wedding brunch also you
can host all different types of meetings
and events at our venue as well although
we are a members only private club we do
welcome non-members to the club to book
their weddings and events what makes us
unique is that we are a One-Stop shop
for your wedding or corporate event for
your wedding for example you can do
everything from planning your bridal
party here to getting ready for your big
day in our spa salon we do full service
spawn Salon amenities so you can get
your hair done and your makeup done with
your bridal party we also have amenities
for the groom and his groomsmen and he
can also get his Shape Up done in our
Barber Shop with a whiskey or a cigar in
our cigar lounge if you would like so
we've got everything to accommodate you
on your big day whether it's your
corporate event or your wedding here at
the Sterling club we offer fully
customizable experiences so if you would
like to work with our preferred vendor
Partners or if you'd like to bring in
your own team we would love to work with
them to create a unique experience for
you and your guests we have multiple
event spaces and venues throughout the
club to choose from to host your event
from our beautiful Grand Warrior to our
intimate blue room or our grand ballroom
that we call the Sterling room we've got
an incredible menu by our executive chef
Leo Barrera he can curate a custom menu
for you on your big day or for your
meeting or event to accommodate your
dietary preferences or specific Styles
or tastes we host intimate Gatherings of
20 people or less up to 150 people for a
seated dinner one thing our guests love
to utilize is our beautiful Grand foyer
and staircase there is a gorgeous
chandelier in the foyer and our couples
love to utilize before your for their
photos and their ceremonies in the past
we have decorated the four year with
beautiful flowers throughout the entire
staircase and railing floating candles
we've had an opera singer and it's been
a really beautiful experience we have
even hosted a wedding where it was
snowing so we can post lots of custom
events we welcome locals and guests from
all over to experience with Sterling
Club contact us today to schedule your
private tour so that we can curate your
neck event or celebration
[Music]
thank you to the Sterling club for
sponsoring that segment for more
information all you got to do is call
702-732-9700 or visit
thesterlingclub.com they have a very
special offer for you listen up mention
Las Vegas now and receive complimentary
pass champagne for the first hour of
your booked wedding party we'll be right
back